sind wir richtig
man kann auch mal durcheinander kommen
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
jetzt ist ja gerade die Ramadan Zeit und
meine Zuschauer wünschen sich dann immer
ganz gerne Rezepte die man gut
vorbereiten kann die könnt ihr natürlich
auch jederzeit zubereiten auch im Herbst
oder Winter im Sommer ganz egal wie Ihr
möchtet ich habe mir jetzt für heute ein
Rezept überlegt mit Hähnchenbrust Gemüse
und Lasagneplatten im Ofen und ich
glaube das wird ein richtig richtig
tolles Rezept ich zeige euch mal kurz
die Zutaten ich verwende dafür etwas
Olivenöl 700 g Hähnchenbrustfilet das
habe ich bereits fein geschnitten 400
Gramm Kartoffeln eine Zwiebel eine
Knoblauchzehe vier rote Paprikaschoten
für grüne Paprikaschoten dann habe ich
hier etwas Tomatenmark und paprika-markt
gemüsebrühpaste Schmand Wasser Salz und
Pfeffer Thymian und Minze das war's auch
schon wie gesagt habe ich die
Hähnchenbrust schon fein gewürfelt und
jetzt habe ich hier die Kartoffeln die
sind auch geschält das Gemüse ist
gewaschen und ich werde jetzt hier
einfach
viel Gemüse ist
wird verwenden tatsächlich zum Würfeln
denn alles hier sollte jetzt gleichmäßig
groß gewürfelt werden das heißt entweder
macht ihr das jetzt hier auf dem
Schneidebrett oder ihr nehmt euren
kenwoodwürfler
so mache ich das jetzt
[Musik]
da kommt natürlich vorne dran
ach jetzt weiß ich warum das
Schnitzelwerk
vorne
jetzt
das Gemüse jetzt einfach so weit
vorbereiten dass es hier oben durch die
Öffnung passt das heißt die großen
Kartoffeln sollten einfach geviertelt
werden und die Paprika einfach entkernen
[Musik]
bei der Grünen Paprika hier oben einfach
reindrücken
und dann könnt ihr den Boden
wegschneiden
und die vier Seiten
könnt quasi ohne zu viel Müll zu
verursachen die Paprika entkernen
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles gut vorbereitet und kann
hier einfach zerkleinert werden
[Musik]
und so macht Gemüse klein schneiden und
kleinwürfeln richtig Spaß
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier die schönen
gleichmäßigen Würfel und ihr seht auch
bei dem Gericht ist der Gemüseanteil
recht hoch ist auch richtig gut so dann
hat man direkt eine ordentliche Portion
Gemüse und eben etwas weniger Fleisch da
kommt hier das Hähnchenfleisch rein
natürlich könnt ihr das ganze auch
vegetarisch machen und kein Fleisch
benutzen oder Tofu verwenden stattdessen
ich gebe jetzt die Knoblauchzehe noch
dazu die habe ich jetzt nicht gewürfelt
während zu große Würfel gewesen
und dann einfach alle restlichen Zutaten
hier rein und alles gut durchmischen
[Musik]
gut die Masse ist jetzt fertig und weil
ich jetzt hier das ganze roh nicht
probieren will dass er Hähnchenfleisch
nehme ich das oft mache so eine kleine
Menge in die Mikrowelle und probiere es
einfach mal vor
dann gab das Hähnchenfleisch durch und
das könnt ihr auch machen
wenn ihr z.B Hackbällchen macht da will
ich auch nicht wirklich großes Fleisch
probieren dann gebe ich auch eine kleine
Menge in die Mikrowelle und fertig oder
wenn ihr keine Mikrowelle habt einfach
auf dem Herz so eine kleine Menge
anbraten und dann weiß man das schon gut
dann nehmt ihr euch jetzt eine Ofenform
ihr könnt jetzt eine Gusseisen Formen
nehmen eine Glasform ich nehme jetzt
hier eine email-form
braucht man eigentlich nicht aber so für
den Geschmack finde ich das schon gut
und dann kommt jetzt erstmal eine erste
Schicht rein und ich schätze ich mache
drei Gemüse hähnchenschichten also kommt
jetzt ein Drittel davon rein
[Musik]
dann etwas Mozzarella drüber geben
da drauf kommen jetzt Lasagneplatten
[Musik]
dann die zweite gemüseschicht
nochmal Mozzarella drüber und es sieht
jetzt ein bisschen trocken aus aber die
Paprika hatte wirklich enorm Wasser
deswegen habe ich da jetzt nicht so eine
mega Soße dazu gemacht denn die Paprika
wird das Wasser verlieren die Nudeln
saugen ist auf und dann wird es am Ende
schätze ich mal ganz gut werden vom
Verhältnis aber wenn ich eine normale
Lasagne macht gucke ich schon dass ich
so eine Soße mit dabei habe aber da habe
ich ja dann auch nicht so viel Paprika
und der Mozzarella da drin der sorgt
dafür dass es schön cremig wird
so jetzt noch mal Lasagneblätter
machen wir die Ecken weg
[Musik]
die letzte Schicht hier ist noch mal
Gemüse fleischschicht
und darauf kommt jetzt die allerletzte
Schicht das ist der geriebene Mozzarella
und dann kann es schon in den Backofen
oder wenn ihr sagt ihr braucht erst
heute abend deckt es ab stellt in den
Kühlschrank und kann alles schön
durchziehen und dann kommt kurz vor dem
Verzeihen in den Backofen so kann man
das Essen wirklich wunderbar vorbereiten
[Musik]
bei uns wird es gleich gegessen also
kommt jetzt direkt in den Backofen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die Lasagne fertig und kann
probiert werden Alex darf weiter
probieren okay
ich habe ganz jetzt auch ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen haben in der Zeit
einfach Fotos gemacht
danke schön wenn es lange gearbeitet
heute und das Abendessen das kriegen wir
schon hin danke schön
probiert tatsächlich aber ich finde so
von der Zubereitung her wenn du weißt
schon heute mit hier im Studio oder hast
du ein bisschen mitgeguckt
cool oder
skeptisch auf die Nudeln wirklich weich
werden aber ja fühlt sich zumindest an
als wenn sie weiß und es ist nicht zu
viel sowas also tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen Soße unten übrig aber es ist
nicht viel das ist nicht so super
und wenn man das so ohne Nudeln macht
dann ist es schon zu soßig und suppig
also sehr sehr gut sehr gut gewürzt ja
kein Salz fehlt Gott sei Dank es ist zu
viel nee okay passt dann mal gespannt
ich liebe ja oben drauf die Käseschicht
ja wie man sagen soll Lasagne es ist
halt am liebsten so richtig richtig heiß
aus dem Ofen aber dann haben wir immer
das Gaumen Problem dafür bringt man sich
ja ja ich habe gerade was ich habe mich
glaube ich doch verbrannt und habe es
irgendwie vergessen
ja gut
schmeckt gut würzig ja Kartoffeln sind
durch viel Gemüse viel Gemüse gut
vorzubereiten
perfekt
für die Ramadan Zeit und es ist eine
richtig große Portion die ihr wirklich
mit wenig Arbeit wenig Werkzeug und in
ganz kurzer Zeit zubereiten könnt also
ich bräuchte dazu tatsächlich nichts
mehr außer vielleicht einen Salat ja
aber ja also wenn man noch was Frisches
dazu will was ich auch sehr gerne mag
Lasagne immer mit heißer Lasagne mit
kalten knackigen
kann richtig gut kann ich nicht ich habe
jetzt erstmal bei dir probiert aber es
schmeckt wirklich gut ja
also probiert das Rezept gerne aus und
schreibt mir auch gerne mal was ihr
jetzt gerade zu Ramadan seid zubereitet
ob es jetzt auch wieder so einfache
Gerichte sind oder Tisch steht da so
richtig auf und sagt euch jetzt kochen
wir so richtig und genießen ist und ähm
machen so richtig ein Familienfest
abends draußen schreibt es mir ganz
gerne und ihr findet doch ganz viele
weitere Rezepte
in unserer Kategorie auf meinem Blog und
in meiner App alles andere verlinke ich
euch ja immer auf Instagram in die
Highlights und dann wünsche ich euch
alles Gute bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]